well first of all I every time they miss
I think it's the stupidest thing ever no
it's true it ain't true
I don't believe it's true
you weren't playing hard enough man
well you know the reason I don't think
is true I just don't remember all those
Denver Nugget championships it's the
first time they ever been to the finals
so they act like this Con they got a
good damn team listen these guys are the
best athletes in the world the notion
that breathing gonna dictate who wins
like I tell you if that was the case the
would have been that's the first
time they ever been to the finals and
all of a sudden now aptitude matters
give me a damn break